the batman is the latest take on one of
the most recognizable superheroes of all
time even the most offhand line in the
film reveals more about the character
than you might think wanna know more
keep watching
i'm vengeance
those two words spotlighted in the
trailer had already become something of
a viral sensation on social media before
the film was released similar to a
familiar line from tim burton's take on
the caped crusader
now you want to get nuts come on let's
get nuts but what's interesting is that
if you search
i'm vengeance on twitter many people
have embraced it in a way that pokes fun
at batman's constant brooding and
self-seriousness which largely mirrors
what happens in the film although batman
doesn't say the line in the presence of
any of the film's main characters that
doesn't stop catwoman from teasing him
about it a few others do as well
treating his declaration like an
embarrassing rage against the machine
lyric he once scribbled in their
yearbook selena kyle teases him at one
point saying come on vengeance obviously
certain elements are intrinsic in the
batman character his parents were
murdered and he has since spent his days
and nights training and planning to
become the ultimate crime deterrent a
big part of his power is the fear he
instills in gotham's criminals so if
there's anyone who could credibly utter
a line like i'm vengeance with complete
sincerity it would be the batman but at
the same time pattinson's batman is just
beginning to come to grips with the
cause and effect his presence has
created in gotham the crime is
relentless the villains are increasingly
more dynamic and his nightly efforts
don't seem to be making much of a dent
overall there's a sense of mere mockery
throughout the batman with characters
like riddler penguin and carmine falcone
treating their adversary's sincerity as
if it's a shortcoming
you got a lot of cats everything about
strength
it's a line spoken coily by selena kyle
in response to batman's less than
genuine observation it also sums up this
take on the character nearly every
action we see from this catwoman is
motivated by the welfare or memory of
someone else she's relentlessly
compassionate toward the vulnerable just
as you'd take in a stray cat and give it
the love it needs to grow however her
biggest motivation is her mission to
save her friend who has gone missing but
like batman she always has the memory of
her murdered mother colouring her
actions then of course there's batman
himself another stray that selena often
pushes cheers up and looks after take a
look at the scene where selena agrees to
wear special contact lenses that
broadcast a video signal to work at the
44 below club hidden within penguin's
iceberg lounge clearly she hates being
an informant for batman but she's
willing to risk her life to help out the
bat and hopefully get some information
on the missing girl's whereabouts in
some ways this take on catwoman might be
the most purely good one fans have seen
in a film sure she technically retains
the skills of a cat burglar but she uses
them to get back stolen passports rather
than steal family jewels arguably she's
every bit the hero the batman is and
unless you're willing to bring up halle
berry's catwoman zoe kravitz's take on
the character is the kindest catwoman
we've seen
the line is sure to get a giggle from
viewers and isn't that what the riddler
is all about that's too delicious i even
gave you a tip off and keep in mind
moviegoers haven't seen a cinematic take
on this character since jim carrey in
1995's batman forever more than anyone
else in batman's rogues gallery the man
typically known as edward nigma seems
made for these times the modern world is
filled with mind games fake news
anonymous troublemakers and other
touchstones the riddler once manipulated
with a pen and piece of paper this is
the perfect opportunity to update the
character into something more
threatening and less cartoonish and the
batman leans into that say hello to my
followers we're live he says at one
point kicking off a live stream with the
intention of holding the district
attorney accountable for his perceived
shortcomings they are here to watch our
little trial the riddler's creepy new
mask off-kilter glasses and defection
for duct tape result in a threatening
new look that no green leotard could
approach his grainy hostage videos and
mocking riddles work perfectly alongside
the user comments in the corners of the
frame riddler uses the tools of social
media to create a formidable army that
mimics him in appearance and technique
while the christopher nolan movies and
the snyder verse both used modern tech
to depict threats to batman neither of
them thought to do so via the riddler
now the character has been reimagined as
a jigsaw-like manipulator for the 21st
century
the potential for further development of
this incarnation of batman's foe and his
followers seems rife with potential
this line comes at a key point in the
film as bruce wayne continues to cling
to any loose string he can find of his
core principles he struggles as gotham
remains a city under siege and a rising
pile of bodies around him serves as
nagging indications he may be fighting a
losing battle carmine falcone one of the
most despicable puppeteers in gotham
solicits the line when he approaches
wayne and tries to bond with him your
father saved my life says the gangster
explaining that thomas wayne once tended
to him you think that doesn't mean
something dismissing the moment as
inconsequential bruce wayne tells
falcone his father did it out of
obligation not friendship that means he
took the hippocratic oath he says what
you're witnessing here is the final
moments of bruce wayne's naive view of
the way the world works in almost every
incarnation of batman thomas and martha
wayne are hugely powerful hugely beloved
characters senselessly gunned down they
are perfect martyrs for batman to avenge
but not in the batman instead further
revelations are to come about how thomas
and martha rose to power silenced their
critics and hid their secrets in short
thomas was far from a noble doctor who
treated everyone equally as the line
becomes blurred between carmine falcone
and thomas wayne it eats away at the
very foundation of the batman mission
could it be that thomas wayne wouldn't
simply help someone out of
professionalism and duty could it be
that falcone was a friend
for all his fancy talk and machiavellian
mind games falcone is just another
homicidal thug this becomes evident in
the final scenes involving the character
when he's confronted by selena their
struggle leads to him nearly strangling
her both bruce wayne and selena kyle
have significant backstories involving
dead parents and their involvement with
the movie's lead gangster falcone
however is a relatively recent creation
in the batman universe he made his debut
in a 1987 comic and although his
criminal activity has often been a
driving force behind gotham's sorry
state this is perhaps the most
influential we've ever seen the
character in essence without falcone
there likely wouldn't be a batman or a
catwoman but during a far more primal
moment falcone tells catwoman you made
me do this just like your mother as he
tries to choke her to death this
confession that he did in fact kill
maria kyle should bring closure for
selena on some level though she's not
able to appreciate it until falcone is
finally knocked off her and arrested
where does selena go from here like
several of the other main characters in
the batman she is essentially a grown
orphan grappling with demons and ghosts
she cannot ignore the last time we see
selena her storyline is resolved she has
no one left to be with and she's heading
off on her motorcycle to start a new
life now it seems she's the stray check
out one of our newest videos right here
plus even more looper videos about the
batman are coming soon subscribe to our
youtube channel and hit the bell so you
don't miss a single one
[Music]
you